trolling lots of squares
now attacks the knight okay but uh
anisha is simply going to move his
knights
um anywhere literally any safe square
should be winning fantasy gary yeah i
almost looked on alireza that he's
his body language is giving up now yeah
the problem is as
you have mentioned what is there to hope
for all of black's pawns are protected
all of black's pieces
are protected pretty much all they're
all on good squares
okay the knight does jump forward now i
would expect anxiety to bring the rook
across yeah to a square that's protected
that's the key but also attacking
white's knight once white's knight
disappears from the sense of the board
okay everything's dropping there's night
checks there's pawns falling
okay well we're going to see it now uh
he's blundered and after that it's going
to be game over
the knight forks the king and the rook
brilliant play by anish yeah ruthless
it's over
already rosie are losing to anish giri
taking anish geary now
to seoul lead again